imagine looking up into the night sky
and seeing not one
but
79 different moons beaming back at you
what would this new sky look like
how would it affect the earth's tides
and how soon would this beautiful sight
bring disaster
this is what if and here's what would
happen if earth had jupiter's 79 moons
jupiter is the biggest planet in our
solar system
with 79 moons it falls just behind
saturn's moon count of 82
and these moons come in different sizes
the teeny tiny s 2010 j2
is two kilometers wide while the massive
ganymede is one and a half times the
size of our moon
jupiter's enormous gravitational pull is
to blame for keeping so many moons in
its orbit
at
778 million kilometers from the sun
it's not losing any moons in a
gravitational tug of war
now imagine all those moons moved to
earth
with so many cluttered objects in our
orbit would they all collide and rain
debris down on earth
with 79 more moons the night sky would
look busier
but since most of the new moons in our
orbit would be less than 10 kilometers
wide
they'd appear more like bright stars at
first glance
but you'd also have the awesome view of
four giant moons beaming right back at
you
those would be io europa
ganymede and callisto
of these europa would be the moon that
looks the most familiar
it's about 90 percent the size of our
moon
but there would be at least one big
difference
europa is covered in ice
well that means it would reflect about
five and a half times more sunlight than
our moon
you'd be wise to wear sunglasses if you
wanted to admire it
even at night
the most dramatic effects of having
jupiter's moons would come from ganymede
while it may be only one and a half
times the size of our moon
it has double its mass
with more of its own gravitational pull
it would have a significant impact on
our tides
yeah get ready for massive tsunamis
extreme earthquakes and more volcanic
activity
earth's tides would be higher too
coastal cities would be flooded and
abandoned
in the united states where 40 percent of
the population lives near the coast
127 million people would be displaced
and so would billions more around the
world
ganymede's gravitational pull could even
be strong enough that the earth would
become tidally locked to it
this would mean that one side of the
planet would always be facing this moon
now this would be good news if you were
on that side of the planet
hopefully you made some investments in
hotel property with a good view of
ganymede
moon tourism would be about to boom
and if you're going to be writing copy
for your new hotel listing you're going
to need grammarly premium
grammarly premium removes repeated words
and expands the vocabulary in your
writing and with their seamless
integration between microsoft office my
browser and my phone i can work from
anywhere on any device
the brochure said there was coffee
included
make your writing exciting and clear no
matter if you're sending an email or
marketing your new bed and breakfast
sign up now and get twenty percent off
at grammarly.com slash what if that's
twenty percent off at g r a m a r
d
what if
hey man you need to clean the jacuzzi
i don't have it
oh my bathtub
you'd also notice that earth's climate
was more stable if ganymede began
orbiting us
that's because a larger moon would
stabilize the angle of earth's rotation
on its axis
usually earth's axis goes back and forth
between an angle of 22.1 to 24 and a
half degrees every 41 000 years
a more stable axis would mean fewer
seasonal changes and no more pesky ice
ages in the future
but if ganymede and all these other
moons invaded our night sky
you wouldn't be able to enjoy the view
for very long
you should expect plenty of havoc
for starters our traditional concept of
a month would become obsolete
months are based around the natural
orbital period of our moon
maybe you'd have 80 months in the year
one for every moon in the sky
and not only months but your entire
concept of a day would likely change
with the gravitational pull of all these
moons the earth's rotation would change
with the gravitational pull of our
current moon the earth's rotation is
expected to slow down to a 30-hour day
billions of years from now and with all
that light from the sun reflecting off
each moon
you'd have to get used to a very bright
night
yeah i hope you're not a light sleeper
but the most chaotic aspect of having so
many new moons would be their
overlapping orbital patterns
many of the satellites currently in
orbit would be at risk of destruction if
they collided with a moon
and it could jeopardize future space
missions too
earth's orbit would be dangerously
clustered
that could mean that the earth might end
up with rings similar to what saturn has
but it could be that the earth doesn't
have a strong enough gravitational pull
to hold all 80 moons in place
those moons would be so close to the sun
that the sun's gravity could win them
over
that could put a few moons on a
collision course with the earth
with all that potential chaos orbiting
earth
you'd probably wish that there weren't
any moons at all
but
that's a story
for another
what if